[Music]
all right amber joins us in little rock
arkansas amber welcome to the ramsay
show
hey george i'm so excited to talk to you
well it's nice that someone's excited to
talk to me for for once it's great to
talk to you amber how can i help
um we are in baby step two okay and i
just have a question about
um our emergency fund and how we're
doing on it um
i have four children and four small dogs
wow busy
yes very busy a lot of creatures a lot
of drool
and our dogs are
you know like our children to us you
know they sleep in bed with us
they're our babies as well
um i'm not comfortable at only a
thousand dollar emergency fund
in case they need to go to the vet if
there's an emergency so you're more
concerned about the dogs than the kids
yeah
what if a kid breaks a leg
amber this is a hilarious scenario here
you're more concerned about the dog vet
bill than you are the kids medical bills
um well luckily they we have very good
insurance um okay so i
i hardly pay anything they have uh two
different coverages okay okay this makes
a lot more sense for them
that's completely free if any children
need to go to the doctor i don't pay
anything but yeah i do pay um like one
of my dogs hurt their leg and i had to
pay four thousand dollars bless you
oh my gosh okay so this makes me nervous
only having a thousand dollars i
understand so how much debt do you have
um
total of 30 000 okay what's the
household income
um my husband makes six thousand and
then i get a month
yes okay i get
2 000 child support and also 800 of a
retirement so like 8 800 total okay and
that's take home
yes so we can get rid of this debt
within a matter of months and get you a
lot more security with a fully funded
emergency fund
yeah we have about um 3 000 a month we
can put towards the debt
okay so that's 10 months i think you can
do it faster than that i think you can
live on less than that and here's the
deal uh i get that a thousand dollars is
scary but i want you to be scared
because debt is scary it's stealing from
your paycheck it's stealing from your
life and so you've got to make a
decision to go i want to take this
uncomfortability and let it fuel me in
my baby step 2 journey as i pay off my
debt using the debt snowball from
smallest to largest regardless of
interest rate and in no time you're
going to build that fully funded
emergency fund but right now you've got
to let this fuel you on your journey to
debt freedom we just took a call from
amber
and it was hilarious she's got four kids
and four dogs and she was more concerned
about the dogs understandably so because
the kids have health insurance but she
was worried about the thousand dollar
emergency fund and it reminded me of
this hilarious article i found from
yahoo life
survey says nearly half of millennials
and gen zers spend money on their pets
social media
this is wild new survey from lending
tree more than one quarter of the 14 25
pet owners polled so 1400 pet owners
were pulled 28 percent said they've
spent money on their pets for social
media posts
oh my gosh
about 47 of jen's ears admitted to the
practice along with 40
of millennials and here's the wild part
when you dig into the numbers the gen z
say they spent the most an average
of
eighteen hundred dollars per month on
their dogs a mix of essentials
subscription boxes pet insurance and the
expenses required for social media fame
y'all if there was a wall i would try to
punch through it right now i don't know
that i'd even make it through the
drywall but this is insane
what are we doing now unless your dog
makes you money
like i'm a big fan of doug the pug and
doug the pug is a multi-millionaire and
i am not so doug the pug is doing
something right but if you're aspiring
to get a pet sponsorship uh and all
these things but you're spending almost
two grand a month to make this happen
this is insane
and then you're telling me uh that the
housing market's too expensive yeah it
is when you're spending two grand a
month on your dog
goodness gracious how cute is your
pomeranian
i have an adorable french bulldog and
yes she does have an instagram but we
rarely post we just did it to stop
bothering people on our own personal
social media feeds and now we don't
spend anywhere near two grand a month on
our french bulldog as expensive as they
are kelly's looking at me with a lot of
judgment right now and i'm i am here for
it i am loving it
so there you go that's
that's some news from yahoo life thank
you for that amazing survey from lending
tree